l'actualité sportive est marqué cette
semaine par le premier match des Bleus
dans le cadre de la Coupe du monde de
football mardi soir l'équipe de France
va affronter l'Australie parmi les 25
joueurs sélectionnés pour se rendre au
Qatar l'attaquant Olivier Giroud le
footballeur a joué pendant deux ans sous
les couleurs du Tour Eiffel c'était il y
a quasiment 15 ans retour en images sur
son passage en terre tourangèle avec
Aurélie Renaud
des sélections en équipe de France on
verra plus tard peut-être c'est tout le
mal que je me souhaite c'est l'un des
premiers plateaux télé d'Olivier Giroud
nous sommes en 2009 et dans les studios
de Tv Tours Val de Loire le footballeur
revient sur son début de carrière
Grenoble
Istres puis son poste d'attaquant aux
Tours FC à l'époque club de Ligue 2
lorsque plusieurs milliers de Tours
enjaux assistaient au match des
rencontres animées par Greg le speaker
du TFC qu'Olivia a quand même un profil
atypique à cette époque il faut se
rappeler quand même Olivier c'est
quelqu'un qui fait 1m93 gaucher qui en
plus se fixateur donc le genre de profil
de joueurs qu'on découvre un peu dans
quand on est à avant centre et Olivier
Giroud avec toutes ses qualités sa force
de travail c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment qui adore jouer au foot tours
mine de rien c'est sa rampe de lancement
qui va le faire connaître au grand
public à l'Europe et au monde entier
aujourd'hui durant sa deuxième saison à
Tours Olivier Giroud deviendra le
meilleur buteur du championnat Daniel
Sanchez était à l'époque son coach au
tour Football Club il se souvient d'un
footballeur très travailleur avec un
fort mental je crois qu'on a toujours
entendu énormément de sa part que ce
soit à Tours ensuite à Montpellier où il
a très très bien réussi il a été
champion de France d'aller après à
Arsenal et dans divers clubs et même
maintenant à 35 36 ans mais je dirais
que c'est normal aussi parce que quand
on est deuxième meilleur buteur de
l'histoire de l'équipe de France il y a
une attente par rapport à lui et je
crois que et comme toujours je dirais il
va très certainement répondre à cette
attente avec ses 49 buts au compteur
l'attaquant de l'AC Milan l'ancienne
jeune pousse du Tour Football Club n'est
plus qu'à deux buts du record de Thierry
Henry